[music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music
] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [music] [applause] [applause] [music] [music] people then go off finally a since today again tilt [music] [music] [music] the
all the time if you are also with our newspaper loyalty yes [music] [music] [applause] the [applause] dear Mr. President Johannes dear Mrs. Federal Chancellor dear Mr. President of the European Commission dear Mr. President of the European Council president of the vice national leagues
has dear Mr President of the Federal Council dear Mr President of the Federal Constitutional Court umbrella to rudi governor of st dear members of the federal government dear Lord Mayor dear ladies and gentlemen and uncle Prime Minister praised renault nido westpha
l london russo et la brévine us dollars wild charlemagne aix la chapelle without [applause] a premium pohlers signature of the controller aldo kuonen decks lachapelle from this place of his fall the frankish emperor charles the great champagne ruled an empire that the territory of today's france and
germany united it very much about the quarrel of his sons and grandsons they divided the empire in 843 in a contract from warts of all people werder werder the battlefield that like no other place after centuries of new wars symbolizes the madness of the first world war to which 17 million people died
fell in motion over the graves, chancellor helmut kohl and president françois mitterrand later reached out to each other a picture of german-french reconciliation charles de gaulle was not very happy in 1963 when the german federal parliament added a preamble to the élysée treaty that stated the goal of great britain's membership in the
e
uropean union today,
with great regret, we are on the
verge of great britain leaving the
european union
right now, this new treaty is
important
mr  give european unity a
big boost
he is the counter-model to mainland first
he shows how the big
challenges can
be solved together he updates the
french-german cooperation and
invites you into a european
framework this is also underlined by the presence
of
the
president of the council and the president of the  romanian
presidency there has hardly been a moment in the history of
the european union
when it was more important that
the german-french tandem works
we are building on a solid
foundation between
germans in frankre  i have 2073 town
twinning our
trade relations are intensive the
german-french youth exchange is
lively the universities cooperate closely
nevertheless i sometimes have the feeling
that germans and french
should get to know each other much better,
that more young people should learn the language of the
other and thus
his intellectual world  literature
should understand its history in the
days of konrad adenauer and charles de
gaulle only a few people had a
television in germany there have been two television programs since
1961 the antennas were
not sufficient to see the programs of the
neighbors
le monde and le figaro we only got
63  in germany if things went well in the
main station with a day delay
today we can
watch every local station in the neighboring country via the internet hear
each other in real time via social
networks read newspapers online the evening before
but who know more
about society the economy the
pol  tics of the other than the analogous
years and only 63
at that time our governments separated
worlds today ministries and
administrations work closely together
the foreign offices know
each other’s africa policy
our soldiers secure
the peace in africa together the
federal parliament and federal council and senate are working ever more closely
together
but when germans and french people discuss
in joint debates
, our compatriots know why we are
together in africa and in our free
time we don't live in completely
different worlds last
sunday evening in germany over
nine million
viewers watched the german crime series the crime scene
who is from dortmund  cologne from
some sometimes even from zurich and
from vienna
but why not from paris
and to see
why don't we watch the same the
similar programs
we finally need a common
public on
both sides of the rhine
we need a new one  dynamism new
ideas new initiatives a renaissance
of enthusiasm that
started so promisingly in 1963 contract
of monkeys can this dynamism unfold
from this place from this day today
a message of friendship goes out that brings
the people of germany and
france together must many
president chancellor mean
ladies and gentlemen
, you are warmly welcome may
this place of german-french
history may the aachen treaty give a
new impetus to our common
european future
how much amitié from koall monde long
live the german-french
friendship
[applause]
[music]
dear celebratory meeting, excellencies
dear citizens of the
partner cities out and aachen dear students dear
Mr President of
the French Republic better always
just the end, ladies and gentlemen, today is an
important day for the german-
french freundesc  haft with the
aachen treaty we renew the
foundation of cooperation between
our countries
we reaffirm that we want to face the great
challenges of our time hand in
hand
we do so in aachen the main
residence of charlemagne or charlemagne
whom we call the father of europe we
do so  so in a place that stands
for a
historical relationship between germany and
france but also for the
starting point of a very different
development
we sign the contract on the 56th
anniversary of the élysée contract of 1963
for sign aachen contract a
document that sets the framework for our
future cooperation
dear in the macro just eight
months ago you were
honored with the charles prize here in this very place
honored for your commitment
to europe and for your ideas for europe and for your
ideas for cooperation between our
two countries in view of the long
epoch of rivali  action and wars
between our countries, it is not a
matter of course that we come together like this today
we should keep
reminding ourselves that it was only after the second world war
in germany in the era of
national socialism that brought
europe to an understanding reconciliation
and finally to friendship
friendship that is now deeply rooted in
our
societies history has thus taken a turn
that could not have been happier for
us we remember the
foresight and determination of konrad adenauer and
sharon bowles
they pushed this process forward with the élysée treaty
and made it
irreversible and  we remember many
other courageous politicians and pioneers
who worked with all their might for the
german-french
friendship but i would like
to name politicians like valerie des cadastral
and helmut schmidt helmut kohl and
françois mitterrand as representatives  so
important are the thousands of
mayors and officials in
our partner cities, those
responsible for the 180
academic exchange program, the eight
million people who could get to know each other over time in connection
with the german-french youth
work
and that's why i welcome representatives from al
[music]
and that  all this could come about was
by no means a matter of course
and it was also by no means as easy
as it is sometimes today that in retrospect also
appears the history of the
emergence of and above all the
ratification of the élysée treaty of
55 and 56 years
that was a thorny road to the in the
picture to stay what was used a lot back then
konrad adenauer as a rose breeder knew
what he was talking about
and yet the élysée treaty turned the
german-french friendship into
a unique relationship
why are we signing a new treaty today
supplemented by an
agreement  our two parliaments,
which will in future work together in a structured way in a parliamentary
assembly of 450 members of parliament
why are we implementing the proposal made
by french president emanuel
makro from his speech at the sorbonne in
september 2017 16 months
later we are doing this because we
are living in special times and  because in these
times there is a need for resolute, unambiguous, clear
and future-oriented answers
on the one hand the europe of today can
hardly be compared to that of 1963,
neither in terms of the depth of integration
nor in terms of the number of
member states on the other hand
but in all our countries
populism and nationalism are increasing  for the first
time a country leaves the european
union with great
britain multilateralism is coming under pressure worldwide whether in
the climate cooperation in world trade
in the acceptance of international
institutions up to the united
nations
74 years after a human life  at the end
of the second world war, seemingly
self-evident things are being called into
question again and therefore,
firstly, our
responsibility within the european
union needs to be re-established, the responsibility of germany
and france in this european
union,
therefore, secondly, we need to
redefine the direction of our
cooperation,
therefore, thirdly, we need one
common understanding of our our
international role which
can lead to joint action and that is why
there is a fourth need for
both peoples to live in common in institutions
but above all in the
daily coexistence of our peoples
and especially in the area close to the border seven
chapters 28 articles
this is the new treaty the treaty  von
aachen we very consciously start with the
chapter europe we are part of the
european union
and as this part we want to contribute to its
success
and i am particularly grateful to the
representatives of the european union
institutions that you dear jean claude
juncker that about donald tusk your dear
klaus johannis that you are here today
meets what we wanted with this
contract
[applause]
is that the contract raises
the questions of peace
and security already in the second chapter integrated in
our joint systems of
collective security, we undertake to
give germany and france every help and support in our power in the event of
an armed attack on their
respective sovereign territories
, and this
includes military means 1
that sounds very easy and also
very self-evident  but that's
not it and that's why we
talked a long time about every word but it is
the necessary conclusion from the
breathtaking path that our
people have taken i would like to take this
opportunity to thank you once again for the french president's invitation
to me on the occasion of the 100th anniversary  s
the end of the first world war we
were at the place where the
armistice would be signed in 1918
and companion and the journey from
that day to now to the
commitment to stand by each
other is nothing but
breathtaking and thank you for
walking in
[applause]
we are developing we are committed to
developing a common
military culture a common
defense industry a common
line on arms exports both
wanted to be fully involved we want to make
our contribution to the emergence of
a european army all of this will
only work if we do this at the same time
as coordinating our
foreign policy  connect and whoever knows that a
lot happens every day, also knows
what it means when we now commit ourselves to taking
responsibility for
foreign policy together and
to representing our interests together,
and that will only succeed if we improve our
development policy  coordinate
and our
neighboring continent africa is mentioned in particular in this context
it is about our future in this
contract and in which this applies to the
areas of culture education research
mobility but also to
sustainable development climate environment and
economic affairs
france and germany want and
must set the pace  be in the
future areas that are responsible for the
prosperity of our european
union we know
we can only ensure social cohesion if
we are economically successful if
education plays a key role
if culture gives us the air to breathe
and we also know time is of the essence the
world is asleep  not europe could not keep its
promise in the year 2000 to be the
leading continent in the world
we have to catch up in
many broad areas and that
means we want to complete the
european internal market and we have to
create a digital internal market  kt
we have to coordinate our research areas
, especially in the field
of artificial intelligence
we have to develop common platforms
these are just a few keywords for the
multitude of tasks that lie ahead of us
the integration towards a
german-french economic area
as it says in the contract with
common rules  includes a lot of
work that lies ahead of us that means
the harmonization of the law in the
relevant areas we
want to think together about the future of work
and we can coordinate a lot more
in our labor market policy
but this is the only way that what
we aim for will be convergence between
our economies  be possible
that includes, of course,
driving the energy turnaround and everyone knows what different positions regarding nuclear energy, renewable energies and coal
we are coming, so a big task for
those who are supposed to be pioneers for
this g  a common space that
résumés are the regions close to the border
and i think it is a good chapter
in this treaty and it might
even be an unusual chapter from a french perspective
because we, the
federalists, of course know that
we prime ministers in
germany have at least as much to
say  we have a federal government
but in france the structure of the
country is different and that is why it is
no coincidence that we are here today in
aachen, a city that not only
speaks as a representative of the situation, the clock stands for the history of
our two countries,
but also as a representative  for the many
cities in the border regions of
our 500 kilometer long border
stands the people of these religions
should in these governments should
develop new ways of cooperation and
they should tell us about their
experiences they are given
special freedom they are allowed to
administer  You know
what that means when I look at everyone who is
otherwise responsible for this,
ladies and gentlemen, they are just
excerpts of what
we have planned and I think the
framework is well set
up with this Aachen Treaty,
but we have to do that  being aware today
the work is not done the
contract has to be lived day by day
and from my own experience i know how
sluggish our answers to new
challenges are
with how much perseverance
decisions are postponed how
often it is said that something is
not possible right now  and that is why the
crucial question is whether behind this
treaty is the decisive will that
really needs to be brought to life for
the german federal government for all
my colleagues who are here today or for
those who cannot be here i say
yes, we have this will,
we have this  unconditional will to do so
and i  ch know that our
federal states also see it the same way and
i know that countless organizations
are waiting for a signal
like this to be able to continue living german french cooperation in the spirit of europe
we will have to work hard to
ensure that we understand each other better and better,
not only linguistically but also mentally
and organizationally and that we
treat
each other with respect for the other culture and see this as an
enrichment of our own
culture and that we can take and convince as many people as possible
on this path
i know that this is a
laborious undertaking
at the end of this path it will be  but be an
infinite enrichment
i would like to
commit myself here and that for the entire
federal government that we will do this with
all our might and with all our hearts long
live the french-german
friendship
[applause]
[music]
ddp
[music  ]
[music]
like the president of the r  epublic
europe europe
600 euro
the migration not always of
european solidarity
june your third cd
that repairs for the gdr but a
bit aggressively
regression in which he with novell the
choristers of all reality idea of
solidarity how it all happened
[music]
[applause  ]
cartoonists opel kadett and dvd
[applause]
it's progressing
geriatrics
[music]
[applause]
the us professional dustin democracy
[music]
democracy
[applause]
elia democracy the democrat barack
obama puts gardasee sensitive helia dem
moto  and bad things long road the
concept 8.7 degrees roche the collège de
france
then sees the seven city more rational
the more rational
[music]
[applause]
[applause  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
fanny law firm szary president the few
days as a guest
the anaheim ducks san francisco now
even if the can was integration of
nebraska well illusory
for the time being alternative
samast integration is through me
it started now call your motto to warn
jakhrani parisozial berlin millions
stable
don't stay your reputation sabina through
[applause]
roll line porsche sales of the ids khalid boulahrouz
dear madam chancellor merkel dear angela dear mr
president  macro
page manuel dear council chairman donald tusk
very clear the commission
president goes juncker semester the
prime minister armin laschet dear lord
mayor
marcel philipp dear ladies and gentlemen i
congratulate you on signing the treaty of
friendship of
aha i am pleased and honored
romania the state of  to represent the council presidency of the
european union
and to be present at the signing ceremony of
this bilateral agreement with deep
european significance
we celebrate this festival in a place that
could not be more symbolic in
aachen the first h  capital of europe at the
time of charlemagne
the élysée treaty signed by chancellor
adenauer and president of the gold
18 years after
the end of the second world war sealed the
friendship between the previously enemy
countries it was
the signing of the elysée treaty
on 22 january 1963 that made the
grandiose political project of
integration possible
the european union of today the
heraf evocation of the spirit of
élysées must give us the energy
again the vision and the efforts of
our predecessors to continue building a
strong and coherent europe
from today not only the spirit
of élysées will inspire us but also the
spirit of aachen
im  in the current european context
, the consolidation of the european
bridge is its fundamental need,
the core of which can only lie in the unity and
solidarity of the member
states. today's ceremony is therefore both
for bilateral cooperation between
paris and berlin and for  the
future of the european union is of
paramount importance
this new treaty is not only an
expression of the will of germany and
france
to strengthen their special and historical ties,
it is also the honest expression of
their commitment to strengthening the
european project
i assure you in the strongest possible terms
that romania in the
constant pursuit of this goal
france and germany was and will
remain
[applause]
the true power of the
german-french engine is
also given by its attraction
the key to a viable
european project is also the
opening of the german-french
cooperation sucks kind of its
integrative approach to the  initiatives
promoted at european level
this is the best way to strengthen the unity
and cohesion of the member
states
despite some disagreements
within the european union
about our common  In the
future of Europe, regarding the rhythm
and direction of our development, I hope
that cohesion will
ultimately prove to be stronger.
The European Union will continue to live in the
future from its openness and the will of
its members to start the
European Union together internally and
externally.
This is also the  the idea
of ​​leading romania during the presidency of the council of
the european union it
is fundamental that the
vision for the future of the union is based on
consensual priorities that
highlight the added value of
the european project reflecting
the needs and objectives of citizens the victory of consensus in  the
german-french relations is
an example to follow
[applause]
at the same time the spirit of achern will accompany us
on the way to the summit that will take place on 9 9
2009 10 in sibiu hermannstadt europe's
self-understanding like rudolf shared
on fundamental values  n
i hope that we will confirm this together in
sibiu hermannstadt whoever
gives the common case ladies and
gentlemen our common message should be
we need a
strong inclusive and corrosive union
that is ready to meet all challenges
only then can we have a clear positive
and hopeful perspective  to
create our common future
[applause]
i can go
madam chancellor merkel excellence
meditation form abdullah frangi ladakh
from thursday the slow
number three dakar so in
[applause]
to take the discussion
the shows have become
la france la gare  de l'est determination
the passion there at times a
bit the dismantling
over 50 gentlemen had turned off cool and the
camera flipped the handle of world
history on the friendship
between the germans and the french set an
everlasting friendship on the way
and we should both be grateful for it
that they over the
explore the bigger picture don’t forget dream europe
just like
the amendment of the élysée treaty of the treaty talks
as much about europe and
about europe as is said about germany
and france in this treaty
article celebration the german-
french friendship is
also a friendship for that reason  was left german
and french and other europeans to
take part in this friendship
and without the german french
friendship we wouldn't be able to do it that
our mission is
also the beginning of the story
namely to bring europe together in peace and
freedom in which we all color i.e.
respect all
special features  all
sensibilities of europe with an entry in the package that we have to move towards the future
there was often war in german-french
history
the neighbors of the germans suffered from the french
that the
little ones suffered a lot there is
the prospect that this will not
happen again  our continent
the peace that the continent needs
to be able to thrive and so the
french-german friendship is the
guarantee for a peaceful future in
europe if germany french your
friendship and they do
the french-german friendship
[applause]
[music]